so i was thinking about what to talk
about tonight you know i usually cover
current events on my show and i want to
briefly touch on what's going on in
virginia first which rod just referenced
quickly uh you know because i think
today
although i don't think that most of the
solutions that we are going to need and
hopefully we'll find in this country
will be
purely through politics and certainly
through the political class that we have
right now
i do think today is an incredibly
incredibly important moment for the the
future of this country what's happening
in virginia right now is sort of a
bellwether for everything that this
conference has been about if if wokism
and leftism and collectivism is going to
continue to be on the march
it's going to go through mcauliffe it's
going to go through virginia and
suddenly in the last two weeks it feels
like maybe that isn't going to happen
and you know i try not to spend too much
time on the self-imposed mental
institution that is twitter but i was
looking around twitter this morning and
you can sort of feel it you can sort of
feel people going man
the anti-woke people if we can get a win
and it doesn't even necessarily mean
that we love everything about yunkan it
doesn't mean that we agree with all his
policies or think he's the best
politician or any of that stuff or the
politicians are the ones to fix it as i
said but if we can get a win right now
just something
that it might
start the turnaround i think we can all
feel that we're finally all kind of
having enough of this right we let it
happen i referenced this last night you
know it was like
all of these kids that were in college
with blue hair and genderless and
screaming at professors and you know
causing uh what was it berkeley to spend
something like four hundred thousand
dollars to secure the campus when very
scary four foot seven ben shapiro showed
up
it's like
he's very small he's actually in my
pocket you guys want to see him
um
there's a feeling though that they've
overstepped right they've really
overstepped overstep by coming for the
kids
we're going to first we're going to
inject the kids with the vaccine and it
really doesn't even matter what you
think about vaccines and in a certain
respect it doesn't even matter what you
think about mandates the fact that the
fda i'm sure many of you saw the video
just a few days ago the fda board was
talking about vaccine mandates for
children and one of the doctors actually
said on video we don't know what it'll
do that's why we have to give it to the
kids i mean this is this is the level of
craziness that we are dealing with right
they are they are using our children as
experiments they are putting people in
masks and locking people at home we know
all of the endless things that this is
doing to us psychologically and
culturally i come from a place called
california
thank you one person doing it the one
other californian here obviously uh
where where it's it's like living in
another country truly i mean these last
couple days in florida where i've seen
your faces people smile and
aren't afraid of you i mean we've done
something so incredibly
dangerous and look how quickly they did
it look how quickly they did it and
that's why last night i said you know
you have to give the devil as do here we
can all run around and say wokism is
ridiculous and these people are buffoons
and they don't know what they're talking
about and they okay fine so be it they
all seem like clowns but you kind of
have to admire it right look how much
destruction they have created in really
a couple years and i know we can talk
about sort of the long march through the
institutions and this was all happening
in colleges 20 years ago i i get it you
know i talked to some of my conservative
friends now you know people that i
thought were were very scary right
wingers like dennis prager and larry
elder and glenn beck and i'll say
something and they'll go yeah dave
that's what i was saying 30 years ago
thank you i appreciate that
but it just in the last couple years
fueled by big tech
this this woke thing has done so much
destruction and that's why i really do
think that this election today
in virginia is so important and it's
funny because i live in california here
we are in florida it should probably
have nothing to do with any of us right
unless any of you here live in virginia
in which case i hope you voted a couple
times before you got here um
unless unless you do it really shouldn't
have anything to do with this i mean the
federalist system was set up so that the
states would be separate and mostly
independent the federal government would
do a little bit to make sure we're you
know in essence not at war and we're
having trade with each other and things
of that nature
but suddenly it feels very important it
feels very important that this virginia
race go the right way because one of the
things that i talk about often on my
show is we need a little hope we need
you know i toured with jordan peterson
he would often talk about that star in
the distance he would reference
pinocchio and when you wish upon a star
and i think we've sort of lost that in
america right now we're all sort of
wandering around we wake up every
morning you go online or you watch the
news you see the next ridiculous thing
that these people are throwing on us
whether it's you know the gender stuff
or the vaccination stuff or just or now
joe biden is going to solve climate i
mean the guy fell asleep at the talk
yesterday did you see that like we are
just inundated with stupidity and we
need we need some hope so i think today
there is some hope
and uh i'll be talking with jonathan
isaac who you guys might know who's the
orlando magic basketball player who's
come out against vaccine mandates we
just add a little talk i'm going to talk
to him yeah
you know it's not an easy feat for a guy
like him you know kyrie irving is the
one that most people know he's a big
star the guy's got probably got 80
million bucks or something jonathan
isaac's only been in league for a couple
years he has a huge bright future that
he's put on the line uh but we just i
don't know if it's even public yet but
we added i'll be interviewing him
tonight
right up here
before j.d vance speaks and he's ready
to step into a wider world and realize
that i don't know that he considers
himself a conservative or a republican
or
that he'd ever thought he'd talk at a
conference like this but he was very
excited to come here and we need that
sort of thing we need more and more
people to realize that
the machine is not going to save us and
again
great let's get yunkan in let's
hopefully get a little signal out to the
system that things you know can turn
around but it's just not the politicians
that are going to save us it's us that
is going to save us that really is the
truth
so
you know i was thinking a lot of people
know
i would say roughly my story you know i
was i was a lefty i was a progressive
and then there's a moment that has uh
been seen probably 50 million times or
something like that on youtube where as
a lefty i sat down with uh conservative
or really libertarian talk show host
larry elder who you all know and we
started talking about systemic racism
and i said larry you know but what about
systemic racism and as a lefty i kind of
just believed it existed because i said
it and that's really what they believe
about a lot of things you just say
something and well i said it so it must
be true and uh i'm sure most of you have
seen the clip but larry really just
disassembled me he did it he did it just
beautifully and and uh sort of like
operating he just had stats and numbers
and went through everything and i don't
know how many people can say that their
best and worst career moment were at the
exact same time but i but i really
believe that i can say that about myself
because it was my worst moment for very
obvious reasons i i got into a debate
not ready not armed with facts not ready
to counter the ideas of someone who i
really should have known has been doing
this for 30 years and he wasn't just
gonna lay over and and just let me you
know run run across him but i think it
was my best moment also because at the
time
we were on aura tv i had i had a big
staff in the control room and we taped
it and it was going to air the next day
and i walked into the control room and
the
producers said to me you know dave we'll
cut that we'll cut that moment that
we're obviously not going to put that up
and i don't know what was going on in my
head exactly but i thought
no we have to leave that that was the
true
moment if if
[Applause]
if there's any purpose of being an
interviewer or trying to explain to
people what i believe or listening to
people who know more than me then when
something true happens we certainly
can't cut that
and
over the next couple days you know it
got cut across youtube and you know all
the usual headlines you know
conservative destroys libtard and the
rest of it and i was like oh god what a
headache this is going to be
but you know within about 48 hours i
started looking at the comments which is
not something i recommend any sane
person do but i was looking and i saw a
lot of people were kind of like you know
seemed like reuben
paid attention seemed like he wanted to
continue the conversation
and i really did and and then i started
having conversations with some of the
people that i referenced earlier like
shapiro and prager and bla and back in
all of these people and i realized that
there was a much wider world and a world
which i think sort of now i can bring
this into why we're all here a world
which we have got to save i mean we are
handing it to people
who don't deserve it and we all know it
right we all know something is very
wrong and you know no matter what
you think you have
they want it and they are coming for it
there is no norm look how different the
world is right now as we stand here on
november 1st 2021 than it was in
february of 2020 right i mean basically
we are we are in a completely different
world in less than two years remember we
used to talk about things just two years
ago less than two years ago we had never
heard the phrase two weeks to flatten
the curve now we don't hear it anymore
because they decided it was useless it
wasn't needed we don't talk about herd
immunity they have just pushed and
pushed and pushed we have you know guys
like fauci up there telling us to double
mask while he's sending emails to his
friends telling them that the masks
don't work and they actually could be
worse because you might touch your face
or you'll adjust your mask more so you
do touch your face more and and that's
not going to work and the litany i don't
have to go into all of the things that
they have all said that they don't do
and gavin newsom you know locking kids
at home while he's eating at french
laundry and every other i mean every
single democrat politician on this you
know the height of absurdity as they
flaunt their own rules and our faces and
all these things but look the world is
very very different and the purpose i
think of this conference and why i
wanted to come here even though it's
it's perhaps a little bit
out of my main lane
is that i don't really care
what our differences are
i really don't i know that some of us in
this room
and i don't mean that to i don't mean
that to be glib or or something i i mean
that i mean that quite literally like i
know we have some political differences
in this room uh for those of you that
saw the panel last night we went through
some of those differences and they
they're pretty intense right these are
deeply held religious and philosophical
and political positions that we hold
differently than each other and that's
important so i don't want to be
dismissive of those important issues and
we will have to deal
with all of those issues but i think
that the purpose of this conference is
to go okay
we got a bigger problem at the moment
the problem is that the same old thing
that caused all of our ancestors to come
to this country
pretty much everyone in this room think
about your ancestors why did they come
here whether you're one generation off
whether you're first generation whether
you're six generations in
everybody
in america in essence
uh with the exception of native
americans and and african americans uh
came here for a better life right by
choice they came here often with
absolutely nothing we all know the story
right i came they came with the suitcase
the clothes they had on the back all of
that stuff we have done an experiment
that is so
profoundly
impactful it's it's so
incredible that we almost can't
understand that it happened we can't
understand how much better i really
believe this how much better our
ancestors were than us because i don't
think that most of our ancestors would
be would be sitting around letting this
happen my two grandfathers who fought in
world war ii i'm pretty sure they
wouldn't be sitting around i don't know
exactly what they would be doing but i
don't think they would be sitting around
letting this happen and we're all
letting it move on us and move on us and
that's why when i say whatever our
differences
might be and again not to diminish them
they are deep they are deep
but if you would like to save this thing
if you think that america is worth
saving you know we have we have half the
country seemingly at the moment that
does not think that this experiment was
good
and and the irony of course is they
never leave right they always tell you
they're going to leave they always tell
us it's like leave i'll buy lena dunham
a ticket go go
already you know let's like get somebody
chelsea handler you gotta go
uh but they don't leave and of course
they don't leave because they have
extraordinary success extraordinary
wealth extraordinary health all of these
things things that
they only take for granted because of
our success
so whatever our you know political
differences are we've got to put them
aside at the moment and then i would say
if we can get some of these wins so
let's say let's say yunkan actually wins
in virginia and it sends a signal right
it sends a signal across the country
holy cow holy cow maybe there's a real
pushback against wokeness you know the
system that we have the federalist
system
that you know these states are supposed
to operate independently in some ways
it's working at its highest level right
now right the states are so profoundly
different right now that in many ways
it's like being in different countries
when i'm in california it is it feels
dark and depressing and everyone's
masked and you can sorta you know i
actually don't leave my house that often
uh because there's just not much to do
and i don't feel like being around a lot
of these people but when i do go
shopping you know you see people and
they've got the mask and they kind of
look glossed over they don't look like
they're thinking they they look deeply
depressed you see this almost everywhere
i live in los angeles which is a
particular brand of the craziness
but in some ways it shows you that the
system's working these people seemingly
want it
right larry elder ran a great campaign i
think for for the recall it did not go
well obviously i campaigned with larry
and the way the media treated larry you
know the la times calling him the black
face of white supremacy i mean the yeah
like stuff that you truly cannot imagine
joe biden showing up a day before the
recall refusing to even say larry
elder's name and calling him a trump
clone a man who grew up in south central
l.a the son of a janitor came from
nothing who has made himself into i
think one of the you know the best
public thinkers that we have in the
country the way they dismissed him and
attacked him and everything else uh but
i mentioned all that because california
seems to want it they've sort of made
their decision we like this we like this
ever expanding state we like the school
boards that have complete control over
us
we'd rather talk about gender pronouns
than fixing the streets or getting the
homeless people off the streets or or
the drugs or the crime that's going up
you know we bring in
the d.a who ruined san francisco i mean
literally san francisco which i was also
in san francisco a couple weeks ago
which is a dystopian nightmare it looks
like blade runner it is just an absolute
nightmare well what happened the d.a of
san francisco became the d.a of los
angeles bernie back there his name's
george gascon and now you're allowed to
in essence steal up to i think it's 850
or 900
worth of stuff and they will not
prosecute you so you can basically walk
into best buy and steal a playstation 5
and four games but if you steal a fifth
game then they're going to get on you it
is
it is just absolutely incredible but i
mentioned this because the experiment is
kind of working california is getting
what it asked for new york is getting
what it asked for you know it's funny as
i'm sure many of you know i was off the
grid i do this august off the grid no
phone no news nothing every year i've
done it for five years
when i came back this year on september
1st adam carolla
hosted my show and he told me everything
that i missed and he told me about
andrew cuomo
in essence being taken out and i didn't
know who the lieutenant governor was i
had no i didn't know if it was a man or
a woman i do absolutely nothing about
the person but i said to him before he
even told me anything i said i guarantee
you whoever it is it will be worse
and congratulations new york it is worse
right i mean there yeah
so that's the point the states in many
ways are breaking apart now i want to
keep this union right we're called the
united states of america united is first
we should keep this thing together we
need some of that glue we've got to do
this or we'll be in some sort of
perpetual low-grade civil war that will
not be good the challenge on us i think
is as the states kind of go in these
different directions and as a sort of
new i would say broader hopefully
conservative movement comes together the
real question will be well okay if
certain places let's say florida is is i
would say the the pinnacle of doing it
right and and ron desantis i actually
met him last week this is a good decent
man and i hope he will run for president
i i hope he will run for president and
and i also think that whether he does or
doesn't and wherever trump fits into all
that the crop of republicans coming up
is really really strong and good and
diverse in the right sense not in the
sense of the word that the left uses um
but as the states go off in different
ways the challenge will be okay so if
florida is going to do it right and
tennessee is going to do it right and
texas is going to do it right well will
the other guys leave us alone
and i don't think the answer is yes as a
matter of fact i'm sure the answer is no
the more successful that florida
continues to be as it brings in police
officers and emt people and nurses that
are getting fired for making personal
decisions as florida brings them in yeah
as florida brings them in and becomes
stronger and becomes a state where the
rule of law matters and basic truth
matters and we're not going to teach
children neo-racism and the rest of it
as these states do these things
and i do think hopefully it will start
happening in virginia now too if today
goes well
the other states they're not going to be
happy with that success they will they
will not leave that alone so i think our
next challenge that we should start
thinking about now is if you live in one
of these states
figure out how to defend that state i
mean that sort of intellectually but i
mean it sort of physically as well
figure out how we're going to make sure
that the states are doing it right
are not going to be under endless
assault from the states that aren't
and with all that being said i do think
we can build something very wide right
now and the difference is again they are
not small
they are not small
okay we talked about some deep religious
stuff last night we talked about
abortion last night these are real
things these are important things but
we've got to save the country first
i have no doubt that every speaker that
you're going to hear for the rest of
today and that you've heard over the
last couple days
wants to live in the same country
wants to live in a country that has been
the great promise it is a dream it is an
extraordinary dream that this thing is
here and we are we are on the precipice
of letting it go so i think we all have
our work to do
and most importantly and i ended my
speech in the vip room with this
yesterday
let's go brandon
thank you everybody enjoy the rest of
the conference thank you
guys if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell